spring and Rick Neuheisel CBS college
football analyst and head coach of the
AAF Arizona hotshots he joins us in the
kondal tire Coaches Corner
Rick how do you assess this horns down
taunting that now the big 12 is gonna be
all in on it this game this weekend well
it's sad commentary that we have to go
this far I mean those those signals have
been being brandished by those two fan
bases for some time now I understand
they don't want a bad look they don't
want the bad sportsmanship on television
but hey listen a little fire in the eyes
of both both sides of this equation is
what we returned to NAND in force so I
can see why Bob Bulls B has offered the
ultimatum but III I'm not sure it was
the right move it just brings more
attention to it if you're Oklahoma's
head coach Lincoln Riley what do you say
to your kids about this let's find
another way to signal our touchdown
which have been all too plentiful this
year I mean goodness gracious is Kyler
Murray on on a tear what a unbelievable
season for a guy that you know oh yeah I
thought his mind would be elsewhere he'd
be trying to protect himself given that
he's already signed this monster deal
with the Oakland A's it's been a
remarkable season for mr. Murray should
he give up baseball and pursue football
absolutely not he is a five nine you
know boar of speed that can go zero to
sixty but as they tell me he's got all
the five tools right for the major
leagues and if I'm not incorrect here
Bryce Harper is gonna sign for a big
month and if he could get anywhere close
to that and have it all guaranteed and
not take the pounding that might
accompany an NFL career I think he's
he's on the right track if your game
planning for tua at Alabama or Kyler at
Oklahoma who's tougher to game plan for
Kyler's because he's got 850 yards
rushing to his unbelievable season 36
touchdowns just two interceptions and
both of them are right around 12 yards
in attempt meaning that they're looking
for chunks yard it's down the field
there's but the problem with both of
them is you cannot you cannot rush with
just four seven dropped back guys seven
guys in coverage doesn't get it done
with the group of receivers that both
these guys enjoy and so with three-man
pressures you see in Murray and Intuit
just sitting back there counting the
house five-man pressures really puts you
in harm's way with Kyler Murray who has
made the big run we all remember the
touchdown run against LSU but he's still
nursing a little bit of a sore knee and
he's not quite the zero-to-sixty threat
that Kyler Murray presents what's the
best upset the upset that's best for
college football this weekend oh
goodness that's a great one
I you know best for college football
would probably be Texas / Oklahoma just
to have Texas back as a brand Tom Herman
has got the Longhorns back in a big 12
championship game in just two years
which is what he was hired to do but if
it were they were they win the the big
12 that would make that conference even
that more compelling going forward I
know everybody in the polls for the big
12 wants Oklahoma to win to keep their
narrow margin ahead of Ohio State right
now but to me if you're just picking an
upset it's best for college football
that would probably be it who do you
think is on the outside looking in on
Monday oh I still given that Ohio State
plays the last game it's almost like an
overtime you know you always pick to go
second so you know what you need what
the objective is given that Ohio State's
gonna watch Oklahoma's game against
Texas and see what that outcome is and
see what the margin of victory is I
think Urban Meyer is going to just put
his ears back and go and the matchup I
know northwestern is pesky and Pat
Fitzgerald wears his heart on his sleeve
and so do his feet so does his team but
I think Ohio State has the wherewithal
as we saw them flex against Michigan and
look faster than the Michigan
defense that we all were lauding Don
Browns defense I I just think they're
going to do what they did in 2014 were
they whitewashed Wisconsin with 59 to 0
drubbing I wouldn't be shocked
I don't know 59 to zeros in the cards
that wouldn't be shocked them to put a
pasting on to see if they can impress
the upholster he's Rick Neuheisel
joining us Continental Tire Coaches
Corner
I've been on the 18 playoff kick I was I
was a forest
now I'm an ADA stand I I don't I don't
know how we remove it in the right
direction okay do you want my vote Rick
are you are you an ADA Staz well I'm
actually at well vist okay and the
reason I've gone past eight to twelve
with the idea that the top four would
then have a by the reason I've done that
is I just think this is all about
financial pie right yeah and as you're
slicing it up the there's going to be a
real hesitancy to give us life to the
group of five if it were eight as you
get to twelve I think it would it would
settle better in the hearts and minds of
those making this financial decision if
you give one slice of that 12 pie to the
group of five then a UCF for a Houston
or you know go back to Boise State those
teams can get into this thing and have
an opportunity and then I think we'll be
at a place where not only does a group
of I've have an opportunity but so too
will all the conferences because it's
not all all conferences are not created
equal they have different financial
issues and trying to appease their fan
bases the passion isn't the same across
the country so for for the pac-12 to get
into the to the dance and to the big 12
to get into the dance I think is
important for those fans to be state
state you know true college football
fans the kind of people that want to go
to the games in November to make sure
that their team still has a shot I know
that you're the head coach of the
Alliance of American football you're
coaching the Arizona hotshots here I'm
curious with the quarterback draft you
just had were Tim Tebow and Colin
Kaepernick eligible to be drafted they
were not on the list both of those guys
I know had a community
patience with Charlie ever saw and who
knows what will happen in the in the
coming days but there also you know that
there's that there's a strategy with
with the salaries of the kids and both
of those guys wanted to negotiate
different salaries and probably
deservedly so so that still going on
behind the scenes but they were not
eligible for the draft the other night
okay but there was conversation with
t-bo's representatives and Kaepernick's
about how much you could pay them to be
the in the alliance of american football
i I understand that yes there's been
conversation whether or not it gets to
the point where either one will
participate we'll wait and see
you got to pony up that money it makes
that league even more relevant you got
to have guys that people are gonna tune
in to see this is under the heading not
in my lane yeah but you understand that
I understand I understand television I
understand
drawing power and there's no question
that Colin Kaepernick didn't and Tim
Tebow would have that whether or not a
upstart new league has the financial
capacity to get that accomplished and
and to give those kinds that got those
guys the kind of exposure that they
because they would do it trying to get
themselves back into the NFL and I think
both would be tremendously successful in
this league you know it you just have to
figure out where that happy medium is in
Manziel he wasn't on the list either he
chose I know he was on the list but he
chose to go ahead and take that Canadian
deal at the time that he did it and I
know the Canadian deal locked him to the
Canadian situation at least for the one
day a year I mean future I don't I don't
know that it's not an impossible but
that's what I've been told
have fun in Atlanta great to talk to you
coach we appreciate your time as always
who's better than you man Happy Holidays
to you and yours and enjoy the weekend
thank you buddy that's Rick Neuheisel
CBS sports college football studio
analyst and also he is the new head
coach of the Arizona hotshots of the
Alliance of American football
Continental Tire proud to be the
exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive what you drive
Continental has a tire for you for more
information visit Continental Tire Kham
Kham turn for what you do for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]